en directo a vamos a lima el presidente
peruano pedro castillo no ha completado
un año de gobierno y ya enfrenta embates
cada vez más fuertes el ejecutivo
intenta responder a un paro agrario y a
otro de transportistas al mismo tiempo
que una comisión del congreso de perú
debatirá del jueves si acusar o no a
castillo ante el congreso por delitos de
organización criminal todo lo anterior
mientras su partido perú libre le pidió
que renunciara a su militancia pues lo
acusan de promover que más de la mitad
de su bancada renunciara y que dos
partidos políticos diferentes se
inscribieran a perú libre vamos entonces
a la capital peruana con nuestro
corresponsal francisco zacarías
francisco buenas noches para usted y
empecemos por los problemas sociales que
tanto afectan al gobierno de castilla
los paros que hay en perú porque son las
protestas y que se exigen
buenas noches pero vive en su tercer día
de un paro nacional de transportes de
carga pesada existe preocupación porque
esto podría generar un desabastecimiento
de alimentos y precisamente la cámara de
comercio de lima señala que la protesta
genera pérdidas por más de 18 millones
de dólares diarios en productos de
agroexportación por otro lado los
gremios agrarios cumplieron un paro de
48 horas en rechazo al desabastecimiento
de fertilizantes mientras que los
maestros marcharon por las calles del
país pidiendo mejoras salariales el
denominador común es en todas las
protestas es que pedro casi no cumpla
sus promesas electorales realice una
política económica reduzca el precio de
los combustibles una última encuesta de
la empresa ipsos revela que el 79 por
ciento de los peruanos considera que la
situación económica se encuentra peor
que hace 12 meses mientras que el 75% de
ellos señala que este gobierno genera
efectos negativos tanto al empleo como
la economía del perú y cual la situación
del castillo en el congreso y con su
propio partido
bueno una comisión de fiscalización del
parlamento está recomendando acusarlo
constitucionalmente por presuntos
delitos de organización criminal
colusión y negociación incompatible el
extenso reporte de más de 300 páginas
con evidencias pone en serios aprietos a
pedro castillo que en estos momentos se
encuentra sin aliados y sin una bancada
que lo respalde desde el parlamento
porque su partido político le acaba
pedir que renuncie porque consideran que
se ha alejado del plan de campaña y está
aplicando una política de neoliberal así
las cosas pedro casi o atraviesa un
momento de difícil porque no solamente
va a tener que enfrentar a sus rivales
derecha sino a sus antiguos socios
políticos ya veremos entonces qué pasa
con el presidente francisco muchas
gracias por el reporte y nosotros
seguimos con los deportes aquí en
directo américa